[Music]
hey Wolf Gang we have another brand-new
clip from Avengers infinity war this is
the most detailed one that we've gotten
so far and it's 54 seconds long I'm not
gonna go into a full analysis on this
trailer like I normally do because just
like you guys I want to enjoy the movie
to the fullest extent that I can when it
comes out but I also understand that
many of you enjoy these clips and it
gets you even more excited to see the
movie so I wanted to make sure you at
least see it if you do not want any
spoilers about Avengers infinity war
even though you clicked on this video
click away now an even bigger spoiler
warning if you're still here you are
about to see footage of when the Hulk or
Bruce Banner smashes into the sanctum
sanctorum and has a conversation with
dr. strange Wong and Tony Stark about
Thanos you've been warned going once
going twice rolling his name again
Thanos he's a plague Tony he invades
planets he takes what he wants he wipes
out half the population
he sent Loki the scene starts off pretty
intense and then gets into some comedic
relief but there are a few key things to
notice here first thing notice how
scared Bruce Banner is I won't get too
into my other theories that I've stated
in other videos but I believe that he
just fought Thanos himself and he was no
match for him also knowing that Thanos
is really who was responsible for the
attack in New York City in the first
Avengers the attack on New York that's
him
what's our time line no telling he has
the power and space stones that already
makes him the strongest creature in the
whole universe if he gets his hands on
all six dollars Tony
the next thing to notice is Tony he says
this is it after Bruce Banner tells him
that Thanos is coming but I believe he
is referring to here is the vision that
he had thanks to the Scarlet Witch in
Avengers age of Ultron and his vision he
sees all of the Avengers dead except for
himself he then sees an attack on planet
Earth by the Chitauri tony has been
paranoid and has been preparing for this
attack ever since age of Ultron were
given insight on this and the Infinity
Ward prelude comics where Tony Stark
says that he is preparing for the end he
then says I'll have to figure out how to
do it alone while showing a hologram of
the new bleeding-edge Iron Man suit so
this is the moment that Tony has been
dreading for years you could destroy
life on a scale hitherto I'm dreamt on
did you seriously just say Hitler
200,000 seriously leaning on the
cauldron of the cosmos no one else I'm
going to allow them if they no stain so
six why don't we just stick this one
down the garbage disposal no can do we
swore an oath to protect the time stone
with our lives the last thing they
noticed is something that we already
kind of knew but this just confirms it
and it's when Bruce says that Thanos
already has two of the Infinity stones
but more importantly this is where he
makes Tony aware that if we get six of
the Infinity stones he'll be unstoppable
or as Doctor Strange says he could
destroy life on a scale hitherto
undreamt of so that's it for my quick
breakdown of this new clip let me know
what you guys think of it in the
comments below and also let me know if
you think that with these new clips and
new trailers coming out if you think
Marvel is being a little too excessive
either way I want to know what you think
and don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to my channel to stay
up-to-date on Avengers infinity war
Marvel and all thanks super hero thank
you so much for watching
woof woof it's not half the population
he said Loki
the attack on New York that's him this
is it what's her timeline no telling he
has the power in space don't